لدى البلدين نفس الرأي حول
مدى معاداة إيران
لأمن واستقرار الشرق
الأوسط ، وبالتالي نعم بالتأكيد لدى إدارة ترامب
والمملكة
العربية السعودية وجهات نظر متشابهة حول إيران.
إن حضور هذا الاجتماع فقط أعطني
إحساسك بالطبيعة المتطورة
للعلاقة بين إسرائيل تحت قيادة
بنيامين نتنياهو والدولة العربية الأكثر اعتدالاً
أمس التقى الملك سلمان
برئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
أبو مازن في الرياض
والعناوين التي خرجت اليوم  وهو
أن الملك طمأن الرئيس أبو
مازن بأن سياسة المملكة تجاه
القضية الفلسطينية لم تتغير
إذا أراد الإسرائيليون أن يظهروا أن هناك
نوعًا من المصافحة تحت الطاولة
بين المملكة وإسرائيل ، فهي
غير موجودة بالفعل.  كان من نسج
خيالهم الذي غاب عن
الصور الرسمية لذلك
الاجتماع ولي العهد الأمير محمود بن سلمان ماذا
لو كان هناك شيء.  يجب قراءة hing في ذلك
وكان هذا الاجتماع ضروريًا لتجنب
أي مزيد من التعقيد
فيما يتعلق بموقف ولي العهد فيما يتعلق
بإسرائيل واجباته التي أفترض أنها جندته
من حضور ذلك الاجتماع ،
يجب ألا يقرأ الناس في غيابه أي
شيء آخر غير  أن الملك
يمثل المملكة العربية السعودية وأن ولي
العهد يتبع أوامر الملك هل يمكننا
التحدث عن العلاقات الأمريكية السعودية التي تهيمن على
عناوين الأخبار في الوقت الحالي الإضرار
بسمعة المملكة
يقول منتقدو ترامب إنه يحمي ولي
عهد المملكة العربية السعودية هل تعلم؟
لا يوجد ما يحمي ولي
العهد ولم يشارك ولم
يشارك قط في مقتل جمار
حاليًا رغم ما قرأه الناس
في التقرير المنشور في
الصحف حول إحاطة قدمتها وكالة
المخابرات المركزية لأعضاء الكونجرس
تخمنوا فيها.  ونفترض أنه نظرًا لوجود
ولي العهد في هذا المنصب
، فلا بد أنه كان على علم
بالقتل وما إلى ذلك  إن
الافتقار إلى المساءلة والشفافية
حول التحقيق في مقتل جمال هو
ما أعتقد أنه يجب أن نتفق على
استمرار هذا الجو السام
حول المملكة وخاصة في
واشنطن في الوقت الحالي عندما تتوقع
أن يكون التحقيق مكتملاً
وهل سيضع غطاءً على  كل شيء أن
عملية المحاكمة جارية
ويجب ألا يتوقع الناس نهائية قبل أن
تنتهي هذه العملية كما تعلمون
لسنوات عديدة ، لقد اتهمنا أشخاص
ليس فقط في الكونجرس الأمريكي ولكن في
وسائل الإعلام الغربية بشكل عام وما إلى
ذلك  نظام قضائي عادل للغاية
الآن يريدون منا أن نتدخل ، لذلك
عندما تسمع تعليقات مثل أمريكا
يجب ألا تنزل أبدًا إلى هذا المستوى من
الإفلاس الأخلاقي ، لن
يلين الكونجرس في جهوده لمحاسبة المملكة
العربية السعودية على الجرائم البشعة ،
هذه الكلمات عن طريق  السناتور
تيم كين ، ما هو ردك جيدًا ،
أعتقد أن السناتور يجب أن يعقد
الكونجرس الخاص به وقادته بنفس
المستوى؟  وأنت تعلم أن الحرب التي
بدأتها أمريكا في العراق كانت على أساس
استخبارات ملفقة فأين
التكافؤ